what we need are a series of good people
to get involved and what I think is
going to happen is that there's going to
be a really decent crop of Republicans
coming up and Will some of them fail us
along the way of course will they ever
get everything that you want done done
no but the the world does not Bend to
your will but on the margins we can
hopefully change it a little bit for the
better so one of those people who most
likely is going to run I've interviewed
her a few times I think she's really
really decent uh is Nikki Haley and she
was on Fox being asked whether she's
about to make an announcement we are in
the New Year how are those tea leaves
looking are you going to run for Preston
well I'm not going to make an
announcement here but when you're
looking at a run for president you look
at two things you first look at does the
current situation push for new
leadership
the second question is am I that person
that could be that new leader yes we
need to go in a New Direction and can I
be that leader yes I think I can be that
leader I was as Governor I took on a
hurting state with double-digit
unemployment and we made it the Beast of
the southeast as Ambassador you know I
took on the world when they tried to
disrespect us and I think I showed what
I'm capable of at the United Nations so
do I think I could be that leader yes
but we are still working through things
and we'll figure it out I've never lost
a race I said that then I'd still say
that now I'm not going to lose now but
the reason I wanted to show you that
clip is because I happen to like Nikki
and I really think she's a decent person
I know some of the most trumpian bass
does not like her for whatever reason I
think they feel like she didn't support
Trump after January 6 or something to
that effect and everyone can make their
own judgment calls on all of those
things but the point is she really did
like the facts are the fact she turned
South Carolina around for sure she was
an incredible U.S ambassador to the U.N
under Trump right getting Trump's
policies across and we did not go to
Crazy Wars under Trump or under her and
I think she would just be another good
voice in the mix so what I really want
to see more than anything is I want to
see a whole bunch of people who are
decent get involved and I think that
that's what we're going to start seeing
foreign
[Music]